NAT TURNER: At
Flatiron, our goal
is to organize the
world's oncology data
and make it useful to patients,
physicians, researchers, life
science companies.
So we want to
aggregate as much data
as we can on cancer
treatment and make
that useful to
those who actually
treat cancer and research drugs.
We met a physician.
I'll always remember
we were all,
oh, there's all this
genomic data and all
this very interesting
stuff with patients.
But then he said,
well, just because you
know someone's biomarker,
or their genetic mutation,
doesn't mean you know
how to treat them.
If they have diabetes,
that changes things.
If their age is between this
range, that changes things.
If the histology of the
disease is this way,
it totally changes things.
If they've had prior treatment,
that totally changes things.
And I only see-- this
is him speaking--
10 patients like this a year.
In the United States
there are 4,900 others.
And so I don't have any idea
what happens in those patients.
And so his big-- and our
big-- ah-ha moment was,
I just want to see that data.
Just bring it to me.
And so that was when we
said, all right, there's
a big opportunity not to just
aggregate the genomic data,
but all this clinical data
on who the patients are,
what drugs they're
getting, are they working.
And doing that at
scale, and then
bringing it back to the
physicians who actually care.